straight ahead on law and crime daily
everything you need to know about day
one of jury selection in derek shovin's
trial from the questions to the defense
to the prosecution how a jury will be
selected for the first former officer
charged with murdering george floyd to
stand trial plus we break down pre-trial
motions an inside look into derek
trovan's possible defense and hear from
the family of george floyd as they sit
in the courtroom for proceedings i miss
my brother and the unusual virtual
hearing for the so-called doomsday cult
couple the breakout room and the vacated
hearing explain why laurie valodebel is
insisting she'd be called welcome
everyone to law on crime daily i'm brian
buckmeyer along with terry austin jury
selection is underway in the trial of
derek chovin charged with murdering
george floyd angela levy is in
minneapolis for us and has the latest on
the tedious process of selecting a fair
and impartial jury
yeah brian jury selection is moving
along here in minneapolis a little
slower than anticipated because of covet
19 restrictions but potential jurors
were told to fill out a questionnaire
that would help streamline the process
12 jury members and four alternates will
be selected to serve in derrick
chauvin's trial potential jurors can be
removed for cause if the judge finds
they cannot be impartial both sides can
also strike a potential juror without
giving a reason that's called a
peremptory strike the defense has up to
15 peremptory strikes and the
prosecution has nine
juror number one is a white male he
works as a chemist
i support the message that
every life should matter equally
i don't believe that the organization
black lives matter necessarily stands
for that
i do think that
you know the phrase and the movement
stand for that jurors are asked how much
they know about the case whether they
participated in demonstrations about
police brutality and how much contact
they have had with police the defense
struck one juror because of his martial
arts background prosecutors questioned
whether the defense really wanted him
removed because he was a person of color
juror number four identifies himself
self-identifies as hispanic
as did the
first juror that was struck by the
defense i disagree that the
juror did not articulate
strongly held opinions he
specifically referenced in his
questionnaire illegality of certain
moves on certain tactics he stated that
he had formed the opinion that
these officers had taken the law into
his own hand their own hands the defense
has provided a race neutral reason for
its stray
and so far two jurors have been selected
to be a part of the final jury that will
be impaneled on march 29th one woman and
one man that woman it was pretty
interesting she said she was actually
super excited to be called for jury duty
we don't hear that very often and when
the judge told her she would be part of
the jury she said awesome
brian
interesting reply but thanks anjanet
jury selection began on day two of
proceedings after prosecutors asked the
judge to halt the trial the judge has
refused now the defense is petitioning
the state supreme court
derrick showdown is facing two charges
second-degree unintentional murder and
second-degree manslaughter prosecutors
also charged chauvin with third degree
murder the judge dismissed the charge
for lack of probable cause the minnesota
court of appeals recently ruled the
trial judge aired in not reinstating the
charge now shoving's defense has filed a
petition for review with the minnesota
supreme court asking the higher court to
review the matter i feel i have an
ethical obligation to my client and to
other criminal defendants to do so
because it was a published published or
excuse me presidential opinion
prosecutors then went back to the court
of appeals asking for a stay in the
trial we have filed with the court of
appeals a motion to
stay the trial pending resolution of
jurisdiction with the court of appeals
and in the appeal the court of appeals
says they are reviewing but have not yet
given a time frame for when their ruling
will come down the trial judge says he
will proceed with jury selection unless
a higher court tells him to stop
with us for legal analysis is criminal
defense attorney julie rundleman along
with terry austin and angenette levy
julie picking the right jury is the
obvious goal during selection what kind
of juror though do you think the
prosecution is looking for
so look i would love to say they're
looking for a fair and impartial jury
but that's not usually what they're
looking for they're looking for someone
they believe is going to at the end of
the day find the defendant guilty
and so that means someone who is
potentially more supportive
or more anti-police
i'm sorry anti-police than
you know some of the other jurors keep
in mind when a defense attorney and
prosecution are deciding who the juror
is going to be neither side really wins
it's really about a battle of one person
getting rid of the other one person one
person getting rid of another and then
there's really a compromise that comes
in as to who the final juror is
yeah defense attorneys often say you
never really get who you love just kind
of who you can like or tolerate terry
two jurors have been selected the first
being a white male chemist who has not
seen the video but has been to the mural
how do you see the selection process
going
brian if i had to characterize this
process it would be slow
and methodical every juror is being
questioned individually and the judge is
asking questions first and then he's
handing it off to defense and defense is
asking the same question the first
question he's asking everyone is if you
had to describe yourself to me when we
just met how would you describe yourself
and then of course he gets into the
details about the questionnaire but i
think it's interesting that the two
people they've selected so far have been
individuals who have said they can keep
an open mind and i think anjanet's point
about the female who was chosen saying
awesome she was very interesting she was
very excited she's i think a chatty
caddy and i think she will be
very interesting on the jury exactly no
anjan are you able to see the jurors or
the court staff what's the general mood
in the courthouse
yeah we are being kept out of the
courthouse we're watching a live feed of
the proceedings and so we can't really
see the jurors coming in and out we are
being kept on the other side of the
courthouse obviously
some of these jurors have expressed
concern about their safety they don't
want their names getting out and we
don't show jurors anyway it's just a big
no-no in court you don't do that so
the mood here i would describe i think
it's a little tense it's not as tense
today there weren't any protesters at
the courthouse but i think it's it's
tense it's it's a serious serious
situation and a big big uh criminal case
so i i think there's reason for a little
bit of tension and concern about
security given what happened last summer
thank you everyone for your contribution
still ahead on law and crime daily why
laurie valo dabel is filing a motion in
court to be called by her married name
but first what will and won't the jury
know about the george floyd case once
they've seeded we break down all the
behind the scenes motions next
[Music]
welcome back each morning before
potential jurors are brought into the
courtroom for the derek children's trial
both sides go over pre-trial motions as
ground rules for when testimony begins
here are some of the rulings
the off-duty minneapolis firefighter who
was present when george floyd died can
talk about what she observed but not
what she believes could have saved him
prosecutors plan to call the minneapolis
police chief who can say derek chovan
employment dates but not the reasoning
for his firing the defense plans to call
use of force experts who are expected to
say that chauvin acted within his
training guidelines dr michael baden who
was hired by george floyd's family to
perform an independent autopsy will not
be called to testify the
cause of death
in my opinion
is asphyxia
due to
compression of the neck
which can
interfere with blood flow and oxygen
going to the brain those findings differ
from hennepin county medical examiner dr
andrew baker who ruled floyd's death was
a homicide caused by a cardiopulmonary
arrest while being restrained by law
enforcement dr baker is expected to
testify
and in another motion the defense tried
to get in evidence from george floyd's
2019 arrest angela levy is live in
minneapolis to explain why the defense
says it's relevant to the ongoing trial
yeah brian the defense is claiming that
this is basically an m.o a modus
operandi for george floyd that when he
encounters police that he swallows drugs
so that they won't be able to find them
during the defense investigation of this
case eric nelson the defense attorney
for eric derek chauvin said that defense
investigators noticed a white powder in
the back of chauvin's police cruiser
that's squad 320. you'll hear a lot
about that throughout the trial
nelson said those drugs were tested by
the state and were found to contain
fentanyl and methamphetamine and that
the drugs belonged to george floyd
in reviewing photographs of squad 320
there appeared to be white substances
throughout the back seat of the squad
car
so myself and some of the other
defendants attorneys and our
investigators went to inspect squad 320.
it was very apparent that what was in
squad 320 was controlled substances
the state of minnesota
then subsequently
had those
substances taken out of the squad car
and it
they are in fact methamphetamine and
fentanyl and they contain the dna of
george floyd
so they are chewed partially chewed up
pills
now judge cahill said that he was not
convinced by eric nelson's arguments he
questioned how this could be relative
relevant since
derrick chauvin may not have even known
about that 2019 arrest or the fact that
george floyd had swallowed drugs in the
past prosecutors say actually during
that 2019 arrest that george floyd was
given medical treatment and he was not
restrained judge cahill told eric nelson
to submit something in writing so he
could reconsider this request
that request had been denied earlier in
the case brian
thanks internet back to analyze the jury
selection and trial of the death of
george floyd uh terry the defense is
clearly focused on the fentanyl and
george floyd's car body and the police
car how do you see that being argued in
court
look i think that that is one of their
bigger arguments they only have a few
arguments one is that you know he died
because of the fentanyl one is that they
were acting properly because they were
you know doing reasonable force and the
other is that he was resisting arrest i
think the whole problem here however
with the fentanyl is that they're going
to make george floyd look like he is a
victim here and i think it's not going
to go over well because basically
they're victim blaming and had it not
been or the knee on his neck he would
not have died so i don't think that that
strategy is necessarily going to be
successful now julie i'm curious about
what you think of this theme i saw the
defense kind of throwing out there that
the jury should measure both sides
equally to me that sounds like they're
not recognizing the prosecution has a
burden here and then it's shared what do
you think yeah so you know any time as a
defense attorney i think one of the big
strategies we always assume they're
going to make is
it is not my burden i can literally sit
here we've often heard them say i can
sit here and sleep the whole time and
still the prosecutor must prove this
case beyond a reasonable doubt and so a
defense attorney has to be very careful
when they're questioning the jury when
they are presenting their evidence or or
even cross-examining individuals that
they make it very clear to the jury that
they have absolutely no burden
whatsoever and it's all in the
prosecutor with that said keep in mind
one of the most important things when
you're picking a jury is for a jury to
to in a sense i hate to say this like
you feel like you can relate to them and
he may view that approach as a way for
him to get the juror to embrace him to
get the jurors to believe that he's
being fair and they want to hear what he
has to say and at the end of the day
maybe they'll go along with what he's
saying versus what the prosecution is
saying we'll see if they like him enough
based on that and jeanette day one was a
false start to jury selection do you get
the sense that trial is finally off to a
running start
i mean all day long they've been
questioning potential jurors so we have
two jurors seated
day two you know it has been full of
questioning of jurors just some motions
at the beginning of the day so
it is up and running until the court of
appeals steps in and tells judge cahill
to stop we don't know if that will
happen so we're just waiting to see of
course we've got two selected we're
waiting for ten more jurors and of
course four alternates so quite some way
to go but first day of jury selection
seems to be productive thank you coming
up on law and crime daily with all eyes
on derrick chopin's murder trial how
will this affect george floyd's civil
case our expert analysis coming up plus
it's lori valo day bell the demands lori
valo was making in court and the ruling
that was made after a breakout session
with the prosecutor you don't want to
miss
[Music]
welcome back a court hearing for the
so-called doomsday cult couple ended
with little information being revealed
terry austin is here to explain what the
secret of meeting could mean
brian it was an odd virtual hearing
attorneys for the couple were scheduled
to talk about their latest motions but
they went into a breakout session with
the prosecution and when they came out
the judge announced the hearing was
vacated lori valo and her husband chad
daypel are charged with concealing and
destroying evidence while valo's
children were reported missing
authorities discovered the bodies of jj
and tyler ryan buried in shallow graves
on daebel's property the couple wed in
hawaii in november 2019. lori valdebell
is now insisting she be called by her
married name the defense wants to move
their trial to another county and are
asking for charges to be dismissed a
status conference is set for april 7th
we had a discussion
uh
outside of the presence of the recording
here it was
reported by the court reporter
and i'll note due to the nature of the
discussion the
reporting of that discussion will be
sealed but we did take a record of our
discussions
after discussions with both council
and in consideration of
what's been presented to the court the
court does find good cause at this time
to vacate the currently scheduled
hearings
here to diamonds to the latest episode
of the doomsday cult couple saga is
criminal defense attorney julie
rendellman and co-host terry austin
terry
what do you think could have happened in
this secret meeting it seemed like a lot
happened but we don't know
yeah and the fact that he vacated the
whole thing and there wasn't any
discussion about anything that was
decided you know we were expecting the
prosecution to ask judge boyce to
exclude that survey that we talked about
that was commissioned by the defense you
know in connection with the change of
venue but there was no decision made as
far as that was concerned and i think
they were talking about
using her married name and maybe there
was an agreement between all of them
that they would in fact use her marinade
it's very strange they're making such a
big deal about this whole issue but
apparently it's very important to laurie
to be known that she's married to chad
david
now julie let's talk about that i keep
thinking that these cases will be
separated but wanting to be called by
your married name when your husband is
also accused of a of a serious crime
how does that make am i reading into
that what's that makes does that make
sense to you
no i i think that there is a deliberate
attempt on her part i think it's a bad
move
as far as i'm concerned i don't think
they're ever going to be separated i
think they're going to end up being
tried together and the worst thing that
as far as i'm concerned lori can do is
show allegiance to the man next to her
who's on trial where the bodies of her
two children were found on his property
so to me i think it's just another
brainwashing cult-like behavior on her
part that she wants to let everyone know
she is loyal to chad dabell she doesn't
want anything to do with valo and that
she's sticking with him to the end and
that's not a good move as far as i'm
concerned i would agree it's going to be
very peculiar when they have to explain
that at trial but we'll be there to see
how it all boils down thank you when we
come back derek shogun's criminal trial
is ongoing but where does a civil case
filed by george floyd's family stand the
legal news you need to know after the
break
welcome back while garrett sherwin is
facing a criminal murder trial a civil
case filed by george floyd's family is
still outstanding
the estate of george floyd filed a
federal civil rights lawsuit against the
city of minneapolis and the four ex-cops
charged in his death the lawsuit was
filed last summer and since then not
much else has been known but comments by
chovin's attorney in court during his
trial are providing insight eric nelson
referred to rule 68 also known as an
offer of judgment suggesting the city
might want to settle
with respect to the civil lawsuit
certainly that i think the court is
aware
um mr floyd's family has filed a civil
lawsuit the city has made a rule 68 a
substantial rule 68 offer
and
the the city
acted in an effort to immediately within
hours to attempt to limit its liability
and distance themselves from this
incident
whether it be for politics or whether it
be simply to potentially mitigate
financial exposure to the city that is
the very nature of bias
george floyd's youngest sister was in
court on behalf of the family and spoke
about what her brother was like
the officer took
a great man
a great father
a great brother
a great uncle
and a great
father he really took a great father he
was so family-oriented
he loved his family
he loved his daughter
gianna meant the world to him
and we would never get that back
back one last time is julie rendelman
and terry austin julie
how could an acquittal or conviction in
the criminal face criminal case sorry
affect the civil case
well i mean there's nothing better um in
a civil arena to be able to say that the
that the def that the defendant meaning
the police officer in this case derek
chovin and the three other officers were
convicted so keep in mind the standard
is higher it's beyond a reasonable doubt
whereas in a civil aspect it's a
preponderance of the evidence so if
you're able to prove it in a criminal
case you sure as heck can prove it in a
civil case so it makes it that much
easier
an acquittal does not rule out uh civil
possibilities again because the standard
is lower but of course there's going to
be more concerns if um any of the
defendants are acquitted because it does
make it a bit tougher in the civil arena
makes sense now terry the lawsuit is
against the city and the four former
officers do you think the city is kind
of waiting to see how these trials go
before deciding if they want to settle
or go to trial
no actually here's what i think i think
the city is really trying to get in and
to get out they know that there might be
an adverse decision as far as chovin is
concerned so i think they did the rule
68 offer because they want to force a
settlement by the plaintiff and if in
fact it's not accepted then the
plaintiff is going to have to cover all
the costs so i think it's a very
strategic move i think it's a smart move
actually and we'll see what happens but
i think the city is expecting really an
adverse decision and they want to
resolve everything they possibly can as
quickly as they possibly can and they're
not going to wait for the criminal trial
if they can avoid waiting for it and
probably like defense attorney eric
nelson said they want to separate
themselves from the defendants being the
forex officers as quickly as possible
makes total sense we'll see how that
plays out julie terry thank you and
thank you for joining us here at long
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]